the first thing I want to do in this
video is given the information given
about this triangle figuring out the
unknowns figuring out the length here
this this value a figuring out this
length in orange be figuring out the
measure of this angle which we'll call
alpha and figuring out in radians and
figuring out the measure of this angle
right over here in blue that we could
call beta so encourage you to pause the
video now and given the information that
we have try to figure out these unknowns
so I'm assuming you've given it a try so
let's see what we can determine so we
know two of the side lengths and they're
the same they both have side lengths too
and they've given us one of the angles
right over here this yellow angle has a
measure of pi over 3 radians so one
thing that jumps out at me is that this
is an isosceles triangle and isosceles
triangle has two sides that are have the
same length so this side is congruent to
that side right over there and so that
means that the base angles the
corresponding base angles are also going
to be congruent and that's just because
this is a property of isosceles
triangles so these two are congruent so
the two base angles are going to be
congruent so that means that beta is
also equal to PI over 3 radians so this
is also beta is also equal to PI over 3
radians now let's think about now what
else can we attempt to figure out well
if we know beta is PI over 3 and we know
this angle in yellow is PI over 3
radians we can figure out what this
angle over here and white is and I don't
know let's call that angle the measure
of that angle let's call it X if we're
thinking in terms of radians x plus this
angle plus PI over 3 radians plus PI
over 3 radians this is the sum of the
interior a PI over 3 this is a sum of
the interior angles of this larger
triangle right over here they're going
to sum up to PI radians if we're
thinking in degrees would be 180 degrees
so those are going to sum up to PI
radians so what's X going to be and this
one you can almost look straight at it
you say oh this is going to be
over three but if you want to solve it a
little bit more systematically you can
subtract these two from both sides and
you get X X is equal to I'll rewrite
this orange pie is 3 PI over 3 PI over 3
this is the same thing as PI minus PI
over 3 minus PI over 3 minus PI over 3
minus PI over 3
which of course 3 PI minus PI minus PI
is going to be PI over 3 PI over 3 so
this angles measure is also PI over 3
radians now that's interesting because
this shows us that this is actually an
equilateral triangle all of the sides
when all of the sides have equal have
the same angle measure that means when
all the angles have the same equal and
have the same angle measure that means
all the sides are going to be congruent
so if this side is 2 this side is 2 then
that means that this inside this this
entire side right over here this entire
side right over here is equal to 2 now
what else can we attempt to figure out
well let's see we know this is PI over 3
radians we know we know that this is pi
we know beta is PI over 3 we know that
this is if we think in degrees 90
degrees which is the same thing as PI
over 2 so if we know these two angles of
a triangle we can figure out what alpha
is we know that alpha we write it here
alpha plus PI over 3 plus PI over 3
Plus this right angle which in radians
is PI over 2 plus PI then white plus PI
over 2 that's this angle right over here
plus PI over 2 are going to equal well
the sum of the interior angles of a
triangle remember we're looking at this
this hat this triangle right over here
that's going to be equal to if we
thought in degrees would be 180 degrees
in radians it would be equal to PI so we
get alpha alpha is equal to is equal to
PI which is the same thing let's see
I'll find a common denominator 6 so say
well can write that as 6 PI over 6
- pi over three which is the same thing
as 2 PI over 6 I'm just subtracting this
from both sides and I wrote it like that
- PI over 2 which is the same thing as 3
PI over 6 and that's going to be equal
to that's going to be equal to 6 minus 2
minus 3 is 1 so that's going to be equal
to PI over 6 alpha is PI over 6 so let
me write that alpha is equal to PI over
6 radians this over here is PI over 6 PI
over 6 radians
now what's interesting about that is
that that shows that alpha is exactly
half of this PI over 3 radians over here
so that is as measure angle at alpha
then this one also has alpha a measure
of alpha radians PI over 6 plus PI over
6 is is PI over 3 now what's interesting
about that is that gives us confidence
that this thing over here is going to be
bisecting this side over here that this
length that this length is equivalent to
this length right over here we are
bisecting this angle and so when we get
to the other side and this is this is an
isosceles triangle we could actually now
prove that these are congruent triangles
that you have a side an angle and a side
side angle side and so this clyde
corresponds to that side so these two
sides need to be congruent now because
these two sides are congruent we know if
this has length B then this also has
length B so we know that B plus B is
equal to 2 is equal to 2 or we could
just say b is equal to 1 B is equal to 1
B is equal to 1 and now we could use
that information to solve for a using
the Pythagorean theorem this is a right
triangle so we could say a squared plus
B squared which is 1 squared is equal to
2 squared is equal to 2 squared or we
could say let's see a squared is going
to be equal to 2 squared minus 1 so it's
going to be
two three I just subtracted one from
both sides and so we would have a is
equal to the square root of 3a is equal
to the square root of three and if you
remember your special right triangles
from geometry class your 30-60-90
triangles you'll recognize that this is
one of them it's but instead of calling
it a 30-60-90 triangle we could call it
a PI over 6 PI over 3 PI over 2 radians
triangle but it really is in degrees
30-60-90 and we see it has the
properties of the 30-60-90 triangle
where the shortest side is or the side
opposite the PI over 6 radians
angel' has has half the length of the
hypotenuse and then the longer and the
longer non hypotenuse side is square
root of 3 times the shorter side the
side opposite the 60-degree angle or the
PI over 3 radians the length of square
root of 3 times the shortest side so
just like that we were able to figure
out all of the missing information in
this now given that what I want to do is
figure out what the sine cosine and
tangent of alpha actually are and I
could have done it for alpha or I could
have done it for for beta but I'll just
do it for alpha and actually I'll leave
it as an exercise to you to do it for
beta so let's figure out so the sine of
alpha and I encourage you to pause the
video and try to think of it what this
is well the sine of alpha is the same as
sine of PI over 6 and remember sohcahtoa
definition so Sokka Toa let me do Toa in
a different color so Toa sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so for this
angle right over here the opposite side
is 1 so this is equal to 1 over the
hypotenuse 1 over 2 so sine of PI over 6
is 1/2 now what is cosine of alpha or
what is cosine of PI over 6 cosine of PI
over 6
well cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so the adjacent side to this angle
that's not the hypotenuse is square root
of 3 and the hypotenuse once again is 2
so the cosine of PI over
six is square root of three over two and
then finally for the tangent of PI over
six for the tangent tangent of PI over 6
PI over six we could just take the sine
over the cosine or we could say it's the
opposite over the adjacent the opposite
is 1 is 1 the opposite angle to alpha is
1 and the adjacent is square root of 3
so it's 1 over the square root of 3 and
if you don't like R at irrational
numbers of the denominator we can
multiply it by the square root of 3 or
the square root of 3 to get square root
of 3 over square root of 3 over 3 and we
are done we have figured out a lot about
this triangle